the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a breakdown video and my last to break
down videos I talked about some of the
big events I think we could see in the
first and second episode of the final
season but today I will be talking about
one of the biggest events in Game of
Thrones history so far I have done my
best to set the stage for this big event
in the north but as you all know I'm not
a writer but I did try to make sure I
talked about each character and their
location while trying to put them in
position for the battle against the
night king so far according to all the
reports about Game of Thrones season 8
they have all basically said the same
thing about this episode the big battle
against the night king should be very
reminiscent of the Battle of the
bastards only bigger obviously there is
a hell of a lot more at stake but not
only that most of the main characters
will be in Winterfell during this
episode and there will be dragons in
this battle of the kings in the north
since the Battle of the bastards took up
nearly that entire episode I am guessing
they will do something very similar with
this battle - we do know they spent over
fifty five nights filming these scenes
so you can bet your ass this battle will
eat up most of the runtime for this
episode it definitely sounds like they
spared no expense now I imagine we will
get a few quick scenes before the battle
begins but we're probably not gonna be
bouncing around from Westeros to Essos
or anything like that in this episode I
am betting the night king will arrive
within the first 15 to 20 minutes of the
episode then the battle will last until
we see the credits keep in mind this
episode will be well over 1 hour in
length most of the episode will involve
the night king so with that being said
let's begin in my breakdown so far I
said the opening scene of the first
episode will begin in Winterfell with
the arrival of Jon Snow and Daenerys
Targaryen then in the second episode the
opening scene will take place in King's
Landing with the arrival euron greyjoy
in the golden company for this episode
the third episode of the season I want
to go back to the north for the opening
scene if you did watch my last video
then you would know by this point in the
season
Jaime Lannister already arrived in
Winterfell with bran in a small army of
his own they were greeted at the gates
was some sort of hostility in the last
episode but now we're gonna begin the
season with a big council meeting in the
main dining hall of Winterfell all of
the main characters including some of
the Stark's Bannerman will be in
attendance for this meeting during the
scene Jaime will have to explain himself
in front of everyone in order for Jaime
to gain everyone's trust he will have to
be like an open book he can't hold back
any information no matter how sensitive
the topic after all brain stark can
always confirm or deny any story that
Jaime tells so this should be very
interesting for starters Jaime needs to
explain what the hell happened at the
dragon pit Cersei agreed to send all of
her banners to the north to fight the
army of the dead but Jaime isn't gonna
be showing up with all of their banners
now is he he needs to tell them Circe's
true intentions euron greyjoy did not
run back to the Iron Islands he was
actually heading to Essos to pick up the
golden company this could also be
something that brain star could confirm
he can say something along the lines of
this is true I saw you're on in the
golden company arrived in King's Landing
this would obviously cause a big
commotion between everyone in the room
we could even hear the northern Lords
start to lash out at Jaime they might
say something like he cannot be trusted
and that he should be killed for all of
his past crimes we might even see Tyrion
get very uncomfortable during the scene
after all Tyrion might know why Cersei
decided to lie about sending them help
if you do remember when Tyrion and
Cersei last spoke we never get to see
how that scene came to an end who knows
what else was said behind closed doors
so when Jaime starts talking about
Cersei lying to their faces try to
remember to keep an eye on Tyrion when
things get tense the look on his face
might be very telling but let's continue
during this scene we're gonna see a lot
of characters question Jaime's motives
along with some of the things that he
has done in the past Jaime will
basically be put on trial very similar
to Littlefinger's final scene only this
one will have a different outcome almost
everyone knows that Jaime and Cersei had
a very close relationship a relationship
that was much closer than just brother
and sister almost everyone knows that
Circe's children were in fact fathered
by Jaime so how do they know that Jaime
isn't lying to them right now like I
said I think these are the times that
bran stark can get involved in the scene
at some point we're also going
have to get the big revelation about how
a brain actually fell from the tower
window many different people are gonna
want to kill Jaime Lannister when that
gets revealed I don't know how they're
gonna do this yet but in my opinion
Jaime will survive that scene somehow
someway I just don't see him getting
killed this early in the season I feel
like he needs to have at least one more
scene with Cersei before she dies
like I said in some of my previous
videos I believe that brain stark will
forgive Jaime for what he had done to
him now everyone else might not forgive
him but I think that Bryan ultimately
will bran most likely believes that
becoming the three-eyed Raven was his
destiny therefore Jaime might get a pass
another way I can see the writer saving
Jaime during the scene is by shifting
everyone's focus to something else
even if bran stark says that he forgives
Jaime we could still hear some of the
other characters speak out against him
but Jaime could get Saved by the Bell
what I mean by that is near the end of
Jaime's questioning something could
happen at Winterfell states that causes
everyone to shift their focus elsewhere
as Jon Sansa and everyone else is
standing there wondering what to do with
Jaime this is when some commotion could
be heard from outside of the castle this
is when torment berrak Lord Commander
EDD and the rest of the Nights Watch can
arrive at the gate now by this time Jon
should already be well aware of what
happened at he's watched by the sea but
nonetheless he might be a little
surprised that torment in barracks
survived that attack when torment and
barek do get there they can confirm
everyone's worst fears what brain saw
happened at eastwatch-by-the-sea is in
fact true the night king did raise
Danny's dragon and he also raised
several giants and he now has brought
the entire army into the north maybe
they can even bring word that some of
the northern castles were attacked
nearby this would send Winterfell into
high alert the castle would obviously go
into an absolute frenzy this is when
brain needs to tell Jon it's time we go
and have a little talk let's go to the
godswood where we can have some privacy
Jon needs to learn the truth about who
his parents are before the night King
gets there because there is always that
possibility that John could die in that
battle therefore he needs to know the
truth now this could actually be a
really nice cliffhanger for the scene in
Winterfell then we can go down to King's
Landing and check in on Cersei before
all hell breaks loose in the north by
mid-season there should be well over a
foot of snow in King's Landing we did
see some flurries begin to fall in this
season 7 finale but now that the night
king is
closer and closer the conditions should
be getting worse throughout most of
Westeros now in the first scene with
Cersei Lannister I think this is when we
can get her nude scene in my last video
I talked about one of the reports they
came out several months ago and in that
report it did say that Cersei Lannister
his body double was brought back for
another nude scene in the final season
since Cersei may be getting naked next
season I think we might get a scene that
indicates Cersei and Euron has taken
their relationship one step further by
having sex in my last video also talked
about why Cersei may need to do
something like this when Cersei and
Euron first met Euron made it very clear
what he actually wanted from Cersei he
did not only want an alliance but he
also wanted Cersei by his side and not
Jaime's Cersei did say that she would
give urine everything that his heart
desired after they won the war however
now that Jaime is gone Euron might
become a little more aggressive with his
approach so far urine has went above and
beyond to serve Cersei
he not only wiped out some of Danny's
allies when he captured the sand snakes
and you're a Greyjoy but he also
destroyed a big portion of Dany ships he
did this when he attacked Theon and Yara
and he also did that when he attacked
the small fleet grey worm used to get to
Casterly Rock now you're on a set sail
once again to pick up the golden company
and so far he hasn't really got anything
in return from Cersei she does keep
promising to give him something in
return but she has yet to deliver well
you're on may shoot his shot one more
time but this time
Cersei could actually deliver Cersei may
feel like she needs to seduce your own
to ensure that he doesn't leave her like
Jaime just did Cersei not only lost her
lover and brother but she also lost the
commander of her army when Jaime left
but she could lose more than that
depending on where Jaime stops on his
way to Winterfell
like I said previously I highly doubt
that Jaime shows up and Winterfell alone
he will most likely gather up as many
troops as possible which in turn makes
Circe's army even smaller knowing this
Cersei may think Ari
Euron has proven himself time and time
again as of right now urine has been
undefeated for Cersei his ships seem to
be damn near unstoppable plus he did
just pick up the golden company who he
spent an awful lot of time with on those
ships who knows how close you're on and
the commander of the golden company
became during that time Cersei might be
thinking if I
you're on I could potentially lose
everything I have gained thus far plus
Tycho's from the iron bank did hen to
that yer on might not stay obediently
for long with all of this in mind Cersei
may seduce your on to keep him happy and
to keep him fighting for her we might
even see her whisper into his ear after
the war is over I will make you my king
after all we know that's what you're on
really once so the scene in King's
Landing could show Cersei and Euron
laying in bed together this is when we
could see her naked in the bed or we
could see her get out of bed to grab a
nightgown or something like that maybe
there is even a knock at the door
similar to what happened when we last
saw Jaime and Cersei and bed together
but this time it could be Qyburn
knocking on the door to deliver some
news after Cersei gets dressed and meet
sky-bird in the next room he can tell
her about the recent reports coming out
of the north this is when Cersei can
learn that the portion of the wall at
eastwatch-by-the-sea has been breached
not only that but the army of the Dead
has already begun wiping out some of the
Stark's Bannerman like houses umber and
Karstark just to name a few
then Qyburn can tell her all of the
ballistas and wildfire are ready and in
position
afterwards we might even see a evil
smile come across Circe's face at this
time it might seem like everything is
falling in a place for her the army of
the dead are invading the north they
have already started to defeat some of
Circe's enemies and it's just a matter
of time before they reach Winterfell
then on the flipside
Cersei now has Euron wrapped around her
finger the golden company are safely
inside of King's Landing and she has
enough wildfire and ballistas to kill a
hundred dragons and level the entire
capital to a pile of ash but in the
meantime let's quickly head over to
Dragonstone to check on Theon Greyjoy
previously on Game of Thrones
Theon Greyjoy was heading to the Iron
Islands in hopes of finding and rescuing
his sister however we all know that was
not where Euron was heading next
as Theon was heading to the Iron Islands
Euron was already in the process of
picking up the golden company by the
time Theon reached the islands Euron may
have already been on his way back to
King's Landing
even though Theon will not find his
sister or uncle at the Iron Islands that
doesn't mean the trip has to be a total
loss hopefully for his sake he is able
to recruit some more men along the way
or possibly even find
some more ships even if they are small
with the size of the crew that theone
has right now the only chance he really
has of successfully completing the
mission is if he approaches it like the
Navy SEALs
Theon's gonna have to wait until
nightfall then silently board your own
ship the silence if he can do this while
nearly all of the men are off the ships
and in the city of King's Landing I
think he has a really good chance of
getting Yara back now that is of course
assuming that yara is even there if
you're on had or taken down into the
dungeons or the black cells then it
would be incredibly difficult for Theon
to pull this off without getting spotted
by some of the guards but if you are
stowing the ship and it's anchored out
in Blackwater Bay Theon can row his
little ass boat as close as possible
then he could swim the rest of the way
if he did that at nighttime no one would
see him coming then he can slip onto the
ship and start cutting people's throats
without making a single sound now that
he has made it back around the coast he
could possibly stop here to regroup
resupply or begin to devise his plan of
attack
what Dragonstone being so close to
King's Landing he should know that's
where your own ships are located at that
time now let's go back up the Winterfell
where the main event is about to begin
the last scene in Winterfell shortly
ended after beric Dondarrion
tormund Giantsbane Dolores ed and the
rest of the Nights Watch arrived at the
gates when they got there they basically
confirmed everyone's worst fears brains
visions along with the reports of
attacks in the north are accurate the
night King did knock down the wall and
he is coming their way next the scene
ended what brain telling Jon they need
to go through the godswood to speak in
private so let's start off right there
with brain and Jon in front of the
weirwood tree obviously I have no idea
how the scene will actually play out but
I imagine when bran tells John the truth
about his parents he will be absolutely
shocked and most likely in disbelief
bran will need to explain everything
maybe bran can even repeat what Ned's
last words were to Jon he could say my
father promised to tell you about your
mother the next time you spoke but since
he is no longer here to do that allow me
to tell you the whole story if bran
repeated Ned's last words to Jon this
would obviously get Jon's attention
because bran would have had no way of
knowing what Ned said to John remember
bran was in a coma the day that Jon left
Winterfell
not even Benjy
could hear what Ned said to John I think
that would be a nice way to set up the
emotional conversation after brain says
that he can go into the whole story
about the tore knee at Harrenhal which
John should have already heard about but
then bran can go into the details about
how Rhaegar never kidnapped Liana and
how they were actually in love and even
got married before John was born now if
I put myself in Jon's shoes I can only
imagine how confusing this must seem the
whole time he thought Ned was his father
but once it does start to sink in John
should begin to understand why Ned kept
his mother a secret for so long the fact
that he never heard Ned say anything bad
about Rhaegar should be a big indication
that this could be true think about it
like this if Rhaegar truly did kidnap
and rape Liana
at some point over the years of jon
living in Winterfell he would have heard
Ned say some pretty nasty things about
Rhaegar but it's pretty clear that never
happened
Ned knew that Rhaegar wasn't guilty of
those crimes and we even got a glimpse
of this when Ned and Robert were having
a conversation about this very topic and
we're now speaking of this oh it's
unspeakable to you well her father dits
your family that was unspeakable what
Rhaegar Targaryen did to your sister the
woman I loved
kill every Targaryen I get my hands on
you can't get your hands on this one can
you Robert couldn't quite understand why
Ned wasn't so angry about what Rhaegar
had done to his sister but Ned just kind
of brushed it off because he knew that
Robert had no idea what really happened
nor could he ever reveal that
information to him at anytime
so speaking of John once he gets past
that initial phase of being in denial he
should start to put all the pieces
together in his head and come to the
realization that he truly is the son of
Rhaegar and Lyanna john will also come
to realize that this means he is related
to Daenerys Targaryen
then another ton of bricks will hit him
when he remembers that she is pregnant
with his child I mean holy [ __ ] imagine
having all that weighing on you right as
you're about to try to save the realm
from extinction
since brain is already out here at the
weirwood tree he might even go inside of
the weirwood net one more time before
the night King gets there at some point
during the season they need to find out
why the night king chose to come back
and attack now and I'm also hoping they
can find out exactly who he is as I'm
sure most of you know I tend
believe that he is a member of House
Stark quite possibly one of the founding
members of the ancient house after brain
does come out of this vision with all
the new information this is when the
night king should arrive at Winterfell
before bran even has time to explain
everything to everyone
the arrival of the night king would
obviously send the entire castle into a
panic all of the men would begin to
scramble to get into position this is
also when we should get a good look at
what type of weapons they had been
making out of all that dragonglass I'm
hoping that ginjury has a brand new
Warhammer made out of dragonglass and
grey worm and the rest of the unsullied
should all have dragonglass spears
anyone using bow and arrows should have
arrow tips made out of dragon glass as
well I also think that we could see
Samwell Tarly give Hearts bane to
another character to use during the
battle I think that Sam will stay close
to bran Gilly and the baby therefore he
can allow a more experienced swordsman
to carry that Valyrian steel sword in a
battle and once again as I said before I
believe that character can be Sir Jorah
Mormont Sam couldn't even make a comment
about how it was his father's sword but
his father never truly cared for him or
even loved him at all
then he can remind Jorah of how it was
his father giora Mormont
Lord Commander at Castle black who did
care for Sam in some way when you
combine that with the fact that Sam and
Jorah are already friends I think it
would make sense if Sam that allow him
to use the sword now when it comes to
the big main event against the night
King I'm not gonna try to sit here and
guess every single little detail that
could happen during the battle but what
I will try to do is predict all the big
death scenes and other things of
importance this battle will most likely
take place in complete darkness this is
the long night after all but I also
imagine there will be an incredible
amount of snow there could even be so
much snow that it's hard for the horses
to move around and if that's the case
that would certainly take away from the
advantage Jon and Danny's army could
have remember when it comes to the night
king's army the only ones who have
horses are the White Walkers we know
that most of Danny's Dothraki Army is on
horseback which does give them a big
advantage they should be able to cut
right through all those whites that are
on foot but it will also be interesting
to see how they hold up in the snow
because the Dothraki are not used to
fighting in that kind of weather or
terrain now when the night King does get
there
first thing people should notice a
winterfell was a big storm coming in
overhead that typically happens whenever
the night king is coming in full force
he brings the storm after all and when
they noticed this someone will have to
sound the alarm then it's go time most
of the soldiers should already be set up
in camp around the castle already so
they should be able to protect
Winterfell from getting over ran with
whites however since the night King is
on a damn dragon he might be able to
strike the castle with his blue flame at
will that is unless Daenerys and or John
can hold him off with the other two
dragons without getting them killed in
the process I'm hoping that bran Stark
is able to stay out in the other
weirwood tree that way he could try to
assist them in any way possible
perhaps brain could even go inside and
I'm area in our wolf pack or try to go
inside of the night Kings dragon or even
the night king himself by this time bran
stark will be at the height of his
powers and what I mean by this is brains
should be able to outmaneuver the night
king in this episode I'm not exactly
sure how they're gonna convey this
during the battle but I'm thinking they
will show how powerful brain is in some
way up until now the night King has been
able to stay one step ahead but now it's
brains turn to deliver that checkmate
when the battle is underway it's gonna
be complete chaos we will see soldiers
literally dropping by the thousands not
only does Daenerys have two dragons but
the night King also has a dragon we
should see soldiers on both sides
dropping like flies unfortunately we
will not only see random characters
getting killed in this episode we are
absolutely gonna lose some of our
beloved characters before the battle
comes to an end I have made a video
about this before but sometime during
the battle we will see beric Dondarrion
give another character to kiss of life
to bring them back from the dead this is
something that Barrack does do in the
books although they haven't revealed
this yet in the television show but I
believe they were saving it for the big
battle there has to be a very good
reason why they kept beric Dondarrion
alive for so long he should have died at
the very end of the third season or at
the latest he should have died at the
beginning of the fourth season after
they went and captured the white
barracks said one last thing to the
Hound before they parted ways we'll meet
again again
[ __ ] oh and all
berrak told the hound that they would
see each other again and I think this is
one of many clues that Barrack will
actually give the Hound the kiss of life
keep in mind that Barrack has had a
connection to the Clegane brothers ever
since the very first season of the show
Ned Stark actually ordered Barrack to go
and kill the mountain but the mountain
ended up killing him instead
then Barrack was killed again by the
Hound both of the Clegane brothers
killed him but in a crazy turn of events
Barrack will actually save the hounds
life then the Hound will eventually go
on and kill his brother Gregor Clegane
so in a crazy roundabout way
Barrack is gonna kill the mountain just
like Ned had ordered him to do only
beric will kill him by saving his
brother The Hound I know this might
sound ridiculous to some of you but go
watch my video about barrack and the
kiss of life then maybe it will make
more sense Sandor Clegane will die
during this battle but Barrack will give
him his own life to bring him back other
characters that I think will die during
the battle our Lord Commander Ed tormund
Giantsbane grey worm yawn Royce Lord
Glover and maybe even Jorah Mormont I
could easily see Jorah Mormont
sacrificing his own life to save
Daenerys if it does come to that he has
said many times that he would die for
Daenerys so maybe he actually does now
we will definitely lose some more main
characters before the show comes to an
end but they have some other purposes to
fulfill before that happens in my
opinion another big moment during the
episode should be the arrival of
Melisandre and the fiery hand when
Melisandre gets there she will sway the
battle in a big way when the fiery hand
enters the battle this should look
pretty awesome the night Kings entire
army has sort of a icy blue look to them
but the fiery Han will have a fire red
look to them this will truly be a battle
of ice versus fire we will see red
flames and blue flames light up the
night sky then we will see soldiers of
ice and soldiers of fire fighting on the
ground it should look pretty damn cool
to see once the numbers from both sides
start to dwindle this is when we need to
somehow get the night King off of that
damn dragon we've had one too many stair
downs between Jon Snow and the night
King for us not to see them battle it
out on the ground one versus one in a
sword fight till the death now how they
get the night King off of the dragon is
anyone's guess maybe brain can take
control of this area and force them to
fresh land into the ground or Daenerys
can kill him with drug on I tend to
believe that Jurgen will kill this
Ariane first symbolic reasons mostly as
I said before drogon was named after
Danny's first husband called Drogo and
Viserion was named after Danny's brother
Viserys since call Drogo killed Viserys
that I think drogon may be the one to
kill Vasari on when that happens
Viserion will most likely slam into the
ground just like he did the first time
when he died only this time he will have
the night king riding on his back when
the dragon comes falling out of the sky
this should bring all of the fighting to
a standstill just like it did when
vissarion died beyond the wall that
didn't just cause john and everyone else
to watch in complete shock but the
whites also stopped at the same time
when the night king comes crashing into
the ground on Vasari on this should
cause all of the whites to stop fighting
because it might be the first time that
the night king has taken some actual
damage now it's not gonna kill him but
it will give John just enough time for
him to do one final thing before he
challenges the night king to a sword
fight as everyone is watching the dragon
hit the ground waiting to see what the
night king does next I think this is
when Melisandre can approach John and
possibly say something to him to trigger
a certain response when John and
Melisandre last spoke Jon told
Melisandre to never returned to the
north but Melisandre had one last piece
of advice for Jon before she left she
told Jon you know the night king is
coming you have seen the army of the
Dead and you know I can help you win
this war
Melisandre said she can help him defeat
the night king but she never said how
she can help him well what is Melisandre
known for doing whenever she wants to
help someone she typically needs to
sacrifice someone in order to do so
Jon basically told her if she ever came
back to the north she would die and
Melisandre said she could help him
defeat the night king well how about we
kill two birds with one stone
in order for Melisandre to help Jon
defeat the night king
she must perform one final sacrifice and
that is the ultimate sacrifice which
means Melisandre must give her own life
in order to do so for those of you that
don't know I made a theory video where I
explained why I believe Melisandre is
actually nice and ISA and I believe Jon
will stab her through the heart to
create the burning red sort of heroes
known as Lightbringer now I know what
some of you may be
thinking how will the sword catch on
fire just by plunging it in the
Melisandre chest in my opinion there are
a ton of clues that suggest Melisandre
is nice and Nisa but I will just briefly
go over some of them in case you haven't
watched my Theory video I believe one of
the first big clues is one of the main
symbols that is directly connected to
Melisandre ever since Melisandre was
introduced we have seen her banners
quite a few times and on her banners is
an actual burning heart this represents
Melisandre heart in my opinion it is or
flag after all and once you plunge a
sword in her chest that sword will
absolutely catch on fire because
Melisandre heart is on fire another
reason why I know this is because we
have been told that Melisandre has a
fire burning inside of her
even when Melisandre is at Castle black
Jon could touch Melisandre skin and it
was always very warm to the touch
she could actually walk around the wall
with wearing nothing but a dress yet
somehow she was never cold
that's because Melisandre has a fire
burning inside of her just like her
banner represents now one of my favorite
clues is when Jon actually smells
Melisandre when I noticed this clue it
absolutely blew my mind because it made
so much sense when Jon and Melisandre
are riding in the elevator cage up to
the top of the wall Jon can smell
Melisandre and it reminds him of only
one thing and that is my kins Forge now
what do we know is always inside of a
forge swords and Fire
Melisandre smells like a freaking
red-hot iron sword do you know what that
means
Melisandre quite literally smells like a
burning sword she doesn't just smell
like fire she smells like a sword dipped
in fire that is a very specific smell
now why the hell would Melisandre smell
like that unless they were trying to
tell us something ladies and gentlemen I
don't know about you but it doesn't get
any clearer to me not to mention
Melisandre told Jon what they could
create together when Melisandre was
trying to seduce Jon at Castle black she
said with us joining we can create
lights now what does she mean by
creating lights I think that could be a
reference to light bringer
so as Viserion is slamming into the
ground this will give Melisandre one
last opportunity to assist Jon in
stopping the night King for good even
though malice on
has arrived to help John he already made
it clear that she would die if she ever
returned when she approaches John in
this moment I think she will say
something that will trigger John to
plunge his sword right into her chest
this might even be a suicide mission for
Melisandre she may already know what she
needs to do after all she did say she
would return to Westeros one last time
and that she would die in this country
so perhaps she already has seen her fate
in the flames now in order for Jonah
fulfill the prophecy Melisandre is gonna
have to get John to stab her which is
why I think she might say something that
would trigger a response from John like
that I'm not sure what it is but you can
fill in the blanks with your own
imagination
once John sword does ignite and
Melisandre falls to the ground we will
see the night King get off of the dead
dragon or up off of the ground then pull
his own a sword off of his back it's
gonna feel like time has completely
frozen in that moment everyone will be
standing in place you're gonna be able
to hear a pin drop as John and the
knight King look into each other's eyes
from across the battlefield knowing that
this fight will end with one of them
dead the fate of the entire realm hangs
in the balance
now as you all know I'm not a writer so
I'm not even gonna try to attempt to
describe this sword fight I imagine it
will be epic or at least I hope so I'm
sure the night king will kick John's ass
for several minutes to the point that it
looks like jon is gonna die but if John
has Lightbringer which i think he will
then you can bet your ass that the my
king is gonna go down the king of winter
will fall where winter has fell before
this is also why a stark must always
remain in Winterfell but if you want to
know more details about why I think the
night king will fall in Winterfell check
out the video down below I know some
people have a problem with the night
king getting defeated in this episode of
the season but to me it does seem like
this is the direction the show is
heading in just by reading all the
reports and knowing which episodes
Miguel supports Nick is directing it
appears as if the battle against the
night king will take place in the third
episode while the battle for the Iron
Throne will take place in the fifth
episode we will learn some more
information about the night king and the
White Walkers but I highly doubt that
they're gonna reveal everything in Game
of Thrones they wanted to continue this
story for as long as possible and I
think that's the main reason why the
first prequel
show is about the long nights just look
at the description of the new prequel
show it says we will learn the true
origin of the White Walkers that tells
me we haven't been told the whole truth
or the full story in Game of Thrones so
just keep that in mind as we head into
the final season but then again these
are just my opinions let me know what
you think will happen by the end of the
episode anyways I want to thank everyone
for watching the video and I also want
to thank all of my supporters on patreon
for supporting this channel have a great
day everyone
I will see you again very soon bye
you